non esiste una vita era centro può
vedere degli errori assurdi di giocatori
ke ho 38 curiosa siete pronti
mettetevi comodi lasciati un bel like
evitiamo sud al primo errore è questo
giocattolo cinese in cui dentro al pony
per fare la coda
vedi il cavallo hanno messo la testa di
numeri
casio abbiamo parenti tommasone si è un
puzzle
diciamo che potevano posizionarlo in
modo diverso system pressione dentro
l'altro stato in oro perché la punta una
prossima sono visti in pratica questo
era un gioco berkani e il camel ha
distrutto è scoperto che dentro c'era un
altro cactus 368 il primo giusto e come
se sapevano che dica nel avrebbe
distrutto che i cani l'avrebbero di
restare lo staggia con per carità tutto
il gatto perché non è proprio la
capitale papa parlando sbagliati per
vivere australia hanno scritto austria
però hanno verso il deserto ai canguri
ovviamente cose che non sono in austria
dovevano scrivere australia
vabbè paura questa è una dozzina che c'è
scritto che la luce ai bambini si per
non aver paura del buio la notte ma una
volta accesa e ancora più inquietante
del buio cioè guardatemi mi sembra che
si affronta la fortunata durante la
notte oggetti questa paura è che ti
sentissi ma io mi immagino i genitori
che non è completa e apricale figli
questi hanno popolato da il foglio lo
aveva destato paura della lampada cioè
un orsetto e tutto campo che con la
testa forse non lo so non sapevano bene
come cucire il corpo del mars ha deciso
di fare delle gambe allungano le mani
che si sono già incluse del maglioncino
contagia chi è che taglierà il
maglioncino e stupidi realtà l'abbiamo
costruito così comunque tanta anche qui
in pratica questa è la regina di cuori
di alice nel paese delle meraviglie però
la regina di cuori l'hanno messa nel 3d
fiori potevano mettere la decina di
cuori dei cuori e le carte veste l'anno
maestà dei tre monti o non fatto un
armadio è un'anatra con quattro gambe
che povertà inquietante anche qui forse
volevano fare un altro animale forse era
una tartaruga il corpo di una tartaruga
e gialla con la testa di una
un'altra auto perché non sopravanzavano
la testa d'anatra forse volevano fare un
gatto cane giallo sia questo è giocato
del dinosauro prendi non solo sembra che
tutti sa molto bene non troppo malato si
segue gli occhi vorrà fredda sta
starnutendo è come avere un inquietante
chiamate ma gira la notte al buio ea
prendere l'acqua dalla cucina che trovi
questo davanti alla povera del re leone
ma gli studi hanno montato gli occhi un
po strano sfuggito più che votato e al
contrario praticamente oppure li ami
invertiti quello dei pastori tra sto qui
forse la nome sono contrario ma hanno
girato il giudizio visto che questo
giocattolo sta vivendo una crisi
d'identità o perché è un elicottero
sopra assistito plame che vuol dire
aeroporti inizialmente addio brutti sono
delle forbici con la punta arrotondata
di wonder woman
però quando le altre sembra che un
dell'uomo berna una gamba praticamente
un giocattolo di harry potter sono cose
che non ho mai visto un giocattolo così
brodo già sembra un triciclo travestito
da scopa con ricotta blu questo perché
la rubata
blu per chi è e poi non lo so sembra che
stiamo orlando forse ha perso i colori
strano perché tutto grande ruote cioè le
parti le mani sono color carne i capelli
color marroncino però tutto il resto blu
chili e mezzo di questo cercate qualcosa
che non va che paura è che tra l'altro
si è scritto fianco sono un bambino golf
divertiamoci steve è sempre uscito da un
film horror importanti a latina vabbè
tutti inquietanti questi giocattoli
poverini bambini che li hanno ricevuti
questo dovrebbe essere un dinosauro
giusto un po in sovrappeso non ho mai
visto di notevole ma pure un coccodrillo
un po più grasso con la gamberale grave
o una lumaca ingrassata evoluta le molto
educativo questo non pensavo di qua
forse qualcuno ha preso la scatola nella
svolta rubano ma lady tata un tacco e la
povera belle è un po spettinata sono un
po caso di messi
cosa succede se gli hanno fatto i denti
e all'impoverimento del viso come più
inquietante perché poi dovrete votare
nei commenti secondo me quella del film
come tante di tutti questo forse vince è
veramente inquietante parecchio povero
wimi dolce vita sarà perché questa era
una immagine di copertina rispetto al
prodotto era tv un palloncino di quelli
un po più resistenti che vi fa
rimbalzare sempre così e messina con
piacere se un po sciolto che il disegno
lo so che oppure è stato fatto male
comunque click bates gli hanno fatto due
nati ad entrambi uno qua non c'è non so
se questo dovrebbe essere qualcos'altro
ma che ha il naso di sotto in realtà
doveva essere la bocca ovvero gli hanno
messo il naso coi baffi sotto
allora hanno fatto il giocattolo di un
torino alessandro audio biglietto però
così può essere un cagnolino
nessuno dei due fa le uova comunque si
fanno c'è scritto che fa la cacca
glitter resistenza capitolato android
non c'entro niente con le uova
magari le uova se le aprì son glitter
non lo so comunque già strano che faccia
le uova festari va letto alla da calcio
è stata stampata un po male sono che
dimenticati alcune parti neanche una ri
hanno azzeccato di almeno una zecca la
nora tra gli sono caduti i fiocchi
c'era scritto che gli store consiglio
che però aveva già un degli occhi di
riserva se questi erano erano gli
occhiali da sole colpevole forse si
levano già fatto di pianadetto questi
occhi non ci piacciono tanto mi teneva
incollati con la colla a caldo con forte
spirito ragazzi dovreste dormire un po
perché avete un po troppo chi ha
effettivamente perché sono tristissimi
sono molto tristi sembrano un po sì
affannati non ha stabilito le
orecchiette così poveri no c'è in che
senso
c'è un orso ma c'è un altro pupazzo
contento perché se uno oggi in qua in
questa te perché sei uscendo un altro
pupazzo da quad essere una tappa
un sacco di un gatto essendo qualcosa
dalla sua faccia non ero lì ma
partorendo hanno riempito questi pupazzi
di altri pupazzi che magari non erano
riuscite è un leone con la faccia di
spongebob 11 c'è allora ho capito non ho
voluto fare perché avete presente quei
giochini che si sono nel supermercato in
quei tizi di sopra mesi i soldini e si
muove tipo l'hanno voluto fare di
spongebob però hanno pensato come non
facciamo affrontiamo produrre
spettacolare non è sotto gravi
facciamo farlo non possiamo farlo
quadrato o rettangolare appoggiarsi
quindi gli hanno fatto le zampe di
davanti dietro risultato il pone tanti
fan cappuccino i marroni di spongebob
bisogno non c'è la stella però è un po
deforme se avete visto guerre stellari
san pietro c'è scritto super deformed
collage quindi almeno sono onesti sia
stato che lo scrivono sarà proprio una
cosa coniata proprio certi livelli
l'imitazione tissimo corrente la spada
laser e anche la squadra landon ha detto
bene andiamo a dormire
oddio forse vinto 3 qui quei tanti non
so se quindi può questo non poi ha
scritto diversamente forse vincerà il
podio primo premio c'è scritto tra
l'altro che è una delle espressioni
reali realistica fa le espressioni vita
reale
perché quello che mio zio che paura
oddio forse questo questo fa paura noti
cioè quella gli occhi sono indemoniati
roma quindi dice che sua madre ha fatto
fare una bambola
una fotografia di lui da bambino ti ho
chiarito ha sicuramente hanno
commissionato a qualcuno di fare una
bambola è noto la foto che vedete qua
vedete la foto di lui da bambino e hanno
creato questa bambola che è in cui e
tantissima tipo cambiato ma perché per
adottare questa cosa orribile ma che fa
una sola c'è scritto che sembra più il
re leone che hanno allungato gli occhi
un po troppo dai questa è l'altra gli
occhi il dato anche questo ha fatto
molta c'è che non va maggie purtroppo
alta e bart bar che guarda la faccia
oddio guardia maggie è arrabbiatissima e
tant è un dio che paura c'è scritto che
questo è
un giocattolo che era in esposizione nel
centro commerciale dove è scattato la
foto questa persona quindi ero pure di
esposizione tipo guardate che bella che
sei dice vesco più costante no quando
del collo della disney world c'è una
think air belle che si sbatta un po
rossetto fondata mangiato un po di
partire con il tetto di un ricordo
superma lesbico
certo
tra l'altro non chi è visto abbiamo
visto che si vendono anche qua e un po
di dominio
però il colore rosso e sembra che stia
lacrimando ancora ignota
mammamia terribile ed identificazione
hanno invertito un paletto l'hotel è
visto adesso la cosa in testa nera è
chiarita al posto della cosa ma pensavo
che ci fosse che non andava bene pensavo
che avessero solo messo la coda delle
orecchie dietro con una cosa amerino e
ragazzi che si erano stati gli errori e
face di giocattoli ma ti sto per se
volete vederne altri lasciati un bel
laiche ora mi lascia un po a 4 caselline
scudi car per vedere i nostri altri
video
l'opportunità è e vorrei dire